I'm in can only move my hand
horizontally and why does it look so
sensual I don't know why it looks so
sensual from what I'm seeing I'm seeing
a horrible spiky haired man acting like
a DJ well likewise oh well okay that's a
little there we go now I'm joining hey
don't you dare point that weird hand at
me your hands just as weird freak quick
run down all right we're starting never
mind
good luck best of luck to you game is on
you grab with a swf and space those are
your grabbing hands after that just good
luck oh hey we got we got a Rando in
here I don't think you said this is
private we might have a try-hard in here
[Music]
you know what what I'll let you know
you're done you are you watching it yeah
okay which finger is the good finger oh
that's that's the good finger okay you
get okay yeah yeah soon as that guy's
thrown at you and then I don't know what
John's doing I'm trying to not just
Shawn myself well it is the other person
isn't like a savant at the game I'm
pretty sure the other person is trying
to do like the the okay sign and then
the thing
in doing like that no actually let me
get a closer look at that they're out of
they're out of grenades all they're
doing is middle finger and then just
like gamers are very mature you guys
gonna kill each other
I was killing myself at this point I
can't even get the pain out of this
grenade okay down down there we go
you got the pin out of the grenade pro
tips over here that is a nice dress yeah
you got it perfect lift that all the way
up I'm race against the clock oh my god
what if I were you yeah how do I do this
safely safely there's no way to do that
okay it's not gonna explode the pin is
out so you can you can mess it at all
you want you even bite it if you want
nothing will happen
all right here's pro tip okay it came
out the pin came out the pin came out
the pin came out the pin came out
am i dying oh no way you're fine no wait
what okay all right you know you're
right it's fine all right so firmly
grasp your hand yes okay and then firmly
grasp it was so close close close my
grasp wasn't so dang firm well you got a
firmer yeah you got a you got a practice
like you're squeezing a squeezing an
avocado to check its ripeness you
squeeze it yeah not like you're
squeezing a tomato
like you're afraid of squishy more like
you're trying to like crush a baby's
head yeah exactly
[Applause]
secondhand huh no I'm gonna like oh okay
well the pain is out again I don't know
if that's actually gonna kill you this
time did you drop this on the ground
yeah well you got two more I'll give you
a pro strat oh you want a pro strat yes
all you gotta do when you when you grab
it flail your hand wildly the pin will
fall off I'm dead serious
okay oh I have an extreme close game
flail oh my god okay okay the flail is
good but you need it you need to shake
it until the pin comes out and then let
go okay do you guys want to go again
yes you [ __ ] are going down this
time
here we go I have no technique for
opening better well that sucks for you I
am as with everything in my life the
master Oh God my hand is my hand becomes
box
okay well [ __ ] no not again replay on
that I'm the master bid and then
followed up by that with everything in
my life I don't speak with an accent
with everything in my life I don't speak
with an accent no no no no no I speak
normally you speak with an accent sure
there bud okay
ping ping shake violently I am shake
more violently don't you see the
violence nope
oh so sorry but that was epic I'm not
sorry
all's fair in love and grenades
I killed Chad I was really trying to
shake it out to shake with right click
that was - yeah that's that's no way to
do it
that's not the right I've given you
enough pro strats it's time for a sweet
shared that the student will beat the
master well thank you for acknowledging
that I was the master this feels weird
to say but you're really good at killing
yourself thank you thank you
oh god I can't see if the pin came out
did the pin come out no is the pendant
come out
you're fine you'll notice there's a
sound it goes between port wing I've got
this one zero games of this I have zero
kills in 18 deaths you may notice in my
score that's my entire career why but
this will be the day I get a sweet kill
here we go here we go baby
speed speed speed this might be a world
record oh is it
I have grenade in hand I have grenade in
hand and I'm shaking
[Laughter]
oh and it just doesn't go anywhere you
gotta throw better but oh you got a
little better you got a live better guy
I'm winning ya win better did iessod
live better this is for all the uno [ __ ]
I had to take if you had to take Annie
oh [ __ ] why is my camera lagging what's
going on with my camera what's going on
I feel like the world's biggest fool oh
yeah you look like good enough I am
shaking like this is a corn on a cob
you're not from Ohio one year feet it's
so easy to wait hold on you do it here
I'm coming out with you guys thank you
it's a nice Club we've got here all
right I have to get one kill you guys
have to understand that give it to you
if I could
hi you don't need to give it to be I
will take it from you I will take it
from you all right speed is the key
between not yet but doing between there
we go you're dead
oh my woman she knew at least I got the
Box open hey guys hi yeah what's up why
do I flip you off
ASF in space yeah yeah
I'm good at opening the box yeah I keep
telling yourself that
I think you're doing great thank you
Deshawn believes in you I really needed
that you know I'm new there's gonna be a
lot of like virgin markiplier Chad
pokeyman memes do it yourself I'm sure I
am so trying very hard o go further go
further though
oh but go further though Oh closer to me
than it was to you know who would ever
do that would ever do that
stop being so weird okay I'm gonna try
lefty and I'm thinking lefty handle be
Luci lefties the goosy yeah come here
you stupid avocado of death no no let's
not have that and why am i camera
breaking I've learned so much from you
much yeah you know I'm getting so close
though okay I have the Box open I have
the pin uh-huh I'm just gonna quickly
try this this will work this will fix it
this will fix my camera my problem is
I'm too I'm distracted by my my camera
being broken that I can't play right
yeah what happened the other 19 times
what hey wait I can move things when I'm
dead we help
I don't know I'm running into with my
face take this you [ __ ] and I move
this grenade from you I'm fighting I'm
fighting you what I'm fighting oh my god
you are I'm pushing the grenade I'll
save you
thanks that's so we I didn't know you
could actually interact with things when
you're dead what that's so GT now just
mess with all of us when you're dead
well I won't be dead in this next one so
it won't even matter cameras fixed baby
cameras so fixed looking good I'm
looking good I feel good
life's good little brain you have in
your brain that will not kill me one
more please mark I need you to stay
alive long enough for him to not
speediest to get to the grenade I am so
good at getting to the grenade because
the thing is I'm actually good at this
game but the throwing is not what I'm
good at
exactly you will see you'll see hero
you're all laughing y'all making jokes
you're cracking jokes you having fun
you're cool kids yeah but I'm not I'm
just gonna take the win where I can get
it yeah okay it's fairly honest oh
please I just need one
what are you trying to do I'm trying to
do literally anything yeah Oh like Kobe
I see ways yes okay is there something
fundamental I don't know about the
throwing for some reason I just feel
like I can't throw I honestly just throw
my arm and then let go of click really
you need to let go of it well yeah
otherwise you're just gonna hold it in
your hand you shouldn't have told me
your strategy
oh god you gotta let go when you throw
rocks in real life you keep holding them
yeah all my friends to get them all
right all right ok so click will give
you a head start this time so you can
kill one of them yeah ok all right well
yeah pin out you shake so you click cats
that's so smart
yeah do you know you're gonna you're
pretty smart sometimes just showing all
the time all right here's the thing
about me I never go easy on anyone ever
is that what you say right before you
Bob my head give you a head start and
then we didn't yes it's ok I don't need
it ok this one's not working choose a
different avocado no this one's gonna
work see unlike you I don't give up on
things once they let me down yeah
hi I'm the winner I also think you guys
are at a disadvantage because you have
to throw it the farthest that's cause I
just have to wing it left or right yeah
yeah okay I just want to bomb one person
that's what I've been saying for 25
deaths you my life is flashing before my
eyes oh that's fine that's the first
time I haven't killed myself in a long
time come on it's not coming out it's no
right damn shame unlike said that better
not be going to me okay that's right
next to your concrete barrier okay but
it's not over yet
oh we're not over yet snake where's my
other grenade oh no no no I do only have
one grenade left in your basket
America's no grenade so you're good yes
absolutely I'll try and push my grenades
to you guys or you can just push mine
out of the corner here yeah okay that's
fair I can't move them it's you can only
move the grenades of someone who's dead
ah it's okay we can go again
Oh God my hand broke Oh No Oh God that's
really unfortunate for you I can't shine
come on this is it goodbye Oh
they're covered in a tire right now I'm
very nimble how's my grundle looking
terrible great
no no closer oh my god I threw it past
you man you were really doing great in
the beginning of this hey I still have
four kills yeah
are you sure okay I swear when they're
in the corner there's nothing you can do
I swear I will help I don't know what
you're doing okay guys it's okay I think
no clue all right we need a game that's
gonna level the playing field a little
more all right yeah let's do Mexican
standoff because I feel like that's one
that I can really no two sessions in
she's already figured you see my DJ dick
your DJ dick did not sound like that
just cuz I have an accent okay does that
mean you get to make fun of me that's
not a that's not true we do it all the
time that's basically exclusively what
people make fun of me for oh god right
hi ABS thank you I know this time yeah I
changed it cuz probably meant took mine
here so I had to change it oh I took
your hair I see how it is high-five no
anyone no send it back it's like a dance
move like I pass it to you good wait
yeah you're kind of doing something
thrown back you look like you took a
little too much Molly before the party
here let's get down to where the real
fun begins I hate this mode my brain
doesn't work this is a good mode how do
we open the gun can we just flick it
open maybe you're good enough it's not
loaded we need to push on the left side
there's a button you push forward to
make the chain me go Opie chain B go oh
yeah Jamie go Opie when you push air see
you see ah I see
okay okay I have the wrong side of the
gun held I'm not even holding it yet you
guys are too advanced no no no I'm
getting a load of cleavage geez Louise
sometimes that's even more deadly than
bullets yeah well when you got a mind of
Steel like me you don't get distracted
by such menial things keep your eye on
the prize oh you are done you uh you
might be rude which is so unfortunate
really what grandma Mildred got behind
her back oh my god why can't it just
like get close to the gonna end the
games like yeah close enough Lucas then
the game would be satisfying to play it
feels like we all just popped LSD and
are now trying to like figure out how
normal things work yeah normal thing is
loading a gun
goddamn card game oh come on this is
totally normal in some places yeah
[Music]
you're gonna fall on the floor maybe oh
that's so sad god dammit how do i how do
I get bullet in gun hole go how in gun
hole impossible do
how about we reset huh for pokeyman I
don't have a gun anymore so we got to
reset no we got a receipt from Peggy
Mike you got it no no no you got a got a
reset got a reset come on come on it's
not fair
come on it's not fair we all got to play
the game everything's fair fair fair
it's all about what's fair so I close
the chamber I have my own project spell
out a word in the bullets maybe if you
throw the bullet hard enough you know I
can't wait to shoot you in the face here
we go here we go here we go it's doing
it doing it we should totally reset
resetting is what we forget how your
hands work never oh not on your life I
really think the we should reset let's
reset let's it's only fair it's only
fair it's only fair do I look very
serious right now yes what I don't know
hold on don't shoot me I couldn't even
if I wanted to perfect it'll be perfect
now all right you're all going down
you're all dead your first mistake was
letting me not die their second mistake
will be a bullet in the face your second
mistake is me pulling your trigger okay
what I finally got it open and then I
swapped hands and I freaking closed it
yeah you know that's a shame that's a
shame and a half you say as you're
probably aiming the gun at my no no no
I'll I'll shoot just Sean first just
drop the bullet in oh I thought you
actually did it oh my god yeah it's it's
not it's not the easiest but that's what
makes it so rewarding when you're as
good as
yeah a lot of talk and very little
action happening look at the scoreboard
I've got one kill in this game mode and
that's something the only time we ever
did it I'm concentrating this game makes
me hate being a human dammit I was so
close it was right there oh my god I
can't even pick up bullets anymore I had
a bullet right there I'm leaving this
the only good thing I've ever done you
know I wasn't even going for that one
you know I wasn't even going for that
one so your attempts at being a petty
dildo is is totally lost I've seen a
petty dildo just a sad look across the
table you'll find one go away it's
sitting on the chamber yeah even it's
not in no it can't be it it's all he
lies yeah both of us evident so on the
back it's what do you mean you can't see
it it's where the trigger would be look
if you don't eating it right at you so I
can't like the depth is gone Ike it's
like balls don't point it at me then
it's gonna be there no matter where I
point it oh my god no oh my god
yes yes yes yes the shoe is now on the
other foot you are done you're done in a
million ways you are gone forever
sayonara surplus I've done it deshaun
it's done nothing but support you yes
can we never do that again
[Music]